Buenas tardes María Clara hay que decir
que es audiencia acaba de comenzar y se
espera mucho Primero porque es un
proceso histórico tú lo mencionabas 86
personas fallecidas después de los
atentados del 13 de noviembre que se
jugaron en esta misma sala del Gran
proceso aquí en el Palacio de justicia
de París y que terminó ese proceso hace
dos meses vuelve este segundo proceso
del segundo ataque terrorista más grande
que ha tenido lugar en suelo francés 15
niños fallecieron 450 personas heridas y
además en un día histórico para este
país como es el 14 de Julio también las
víctimas buscan respuestas quieren saber
qué les pueden decir los siete acusados
presentes de las intenciones de este
sujeto para cometer una masacre como la
de ese 14 de Julio con ese camión de 19
toneladas se sabe que quizás no van a
encontrar respuestas Pues estas personas
no estaban involucradas directamente no
son coautores tres de ellos están por
asociación para cometer actos
terroristas pero básicamente porque
podían intuir o saber las intenciones de
la autora del ataque y cuatro de ellos
por infracciones a la ley del porte de
armas y ni siquiera lo conocían y en
último lugar para también a tener ese
reconocimiento como víctima venir aquí
contar su historia poner en común una
historia una tristeza e intentar quizás
así pasar página a un hecho tan horrible
como este